hey guys goodness I have a fitness app
you get to work out life with me and
other amazing trainers every single day
go on down appear on the App Store or go
to feel life calm and start your journey
to become hi guys it's Joanna here and I
got my big guy with me hey how a lot of
you I mean in fact all of you haven't
met Terrence yet what's interesting
about us is that I'm actually my first
language is actually English and
Terrance's first language is actually
meandering party yes so what I mean he
understands English I understand
Mandarin a little bit but we've decided
to keep this video interesting in a
sense that I'll be speaking in English
and tyrants ye how it my way i'ma be
highly those of you who have been
following me on Instagram especially on
my instant stories I'm sure you have
seen my meal prep pictures actually
those meal preps are done by Terrence
great oh yeah you know what I tell you
mentality to base here so it's actually
really simple terrorists will be
prepping the meat the fish the chicken
and the beef and I'll be prepping the
vegetables so this meal prep will be
enough for lunch and dinner it's going
to be for his portion and also my
portion and obviously his question is
way bigger compared to mine so here are
the ingredients we'll be using for the
meal prep about 500 grams of chicken
breast about 300 grams of beef 400 grams
of salmon filet 400 grams of perch 2
medium carrots or 1 large carrot 1 head
of broccoli cherry tomatoes about half a
cup 1 cup 2 sweet potatoes as well as
lots of herbs and spices researching
here what gentleman said young kid she
is a good teacher on y'all can go to
your house pad and hold one jab at his
back to Oklahoma to jump to the what is
it okay so whichever the Teva so he walk
away but her here
you know I'm happier with ya so what she
has me into the hot hideaway okay so it
didn't do her toe time I would have new
pretty media you think actually I only
eat fish so for those of you who are
wondering and pescetarian I'm a
pescetarian so I don't eat any of those
chicken or beef so only fish hands
that's always there's always at least
two varieties of fish salmon perch which
is what we're having right now or at
least another Saba fish
so what Tyrus is doing right now he's
going to marinate the chicken breast
with mixed helps the reason why we like
to use herps to marinate is because it
there's almost zero calories but you get
to flavor your food and it makes your
food taste so good without the
additional fat cream which you just
don't need in your diet to tell you and
it's the conquering the Jiwon India
really otherwise more usual how're you
doing okay
and actually Terrance has been competing
in men's physique bodybuilding for the
past 5 years hence he has been cooking
and new prepping for himself for the
past 10 years right so you know what
he's doing whereas for me I'm just gonna
start slicing and prepping the
vegetables so I like to thinly slice my
vegetables so that it cooks quicker
he likes to do his broccoli a certain
way to actually remove the hard part of
the skin whereas for me for me is
whatever man as long as it goes into my
body I enjoy the food it's good enough
Oh pika she imparted bocalee that anchor
had a white piece of Judea
here it says yeah boy we can call it a
tree erpg was our hope kinnison Allah
and Allah likes to Martin Allah open
catch nala it's everything
holla holla man I mean who waits
avoiding man by p.m. see I never learned
cooking professionally before that's why
I believe that if I can cook anybody can
cook I mean look at the way I'm slicing
things cuz I literally learn how to cook
for myself when I lived alone in the UK
that's when I started and I didn't know
what to do I just thought that slicing
and cooking and just you know even if it
doesn't taste good even if they looked
horrible
I just ate it it doesn't matter see that
build idea - Wow yay hello this is done
we have prepped all the meat and the
vegetables now Terrance you'll be
cooking and I'll be as usual boiling the
vegetables okay so each animal charity -
took a gyro Thurmond neural can take
fiery so can't you engine that simple
son you know now you have a city booted
back so which are you belong to her he
uses very little oil to be honest and
the thing is that because when you cook
salmon and
me you know basically when you cook
salmon especially produces a lot of oil
so you don't need that extra oil
the know they will be but her mother she
particle cool saturated you mean
something new home
say what so how much go to reserve a
pasture the Obamas are not to be opinion
go okay yeah
he's young row
[Music]
so I'm going to buy my broccoli really
quickly just for maybe five five minutes
or so because I like it quite hard and
especially when a male crap you don't
want it to go soft because you're going
to keep it throughout the day that will
- oh wait you - Ichi - herecome when
Dewback has poor either trigger you the
CTO charger or if I am G chord you play
Type R in your opens up you are young
man who like to don't see man was
relativity aha
I'm already hungry has its event yeah so
this is already done it took about three
to four minutes
so you see want to keep your broccoli
green okay if it turns yellow that means
you have overcooked your protein okay
yeah yeah those sons on quite a show to
get high Chula your nephew is immune
well Curtis we pass through due to that
rather than just eating out so you mean
or the sources some satellites are so it
was Ubu sort of our services on which
you learn so much for being here
that's at the engine all right maybe cuz
of the deal
how
so the salmon is done it's well done but
it's not overcooked so it's too moist
and delicious and basically now we have
to allow all the food to cool down
before we can pack it into our container
story the other chicken breast
salmon and we're just going to let it
cool down and Terrance is going to
continue cooking the perch as well as
the beef Nala not for you however yes we
overcook you're making Dorinda oh oh
wait do you overcook lehavot sir I have
to say this is my favorite fish I love
to eat this fish it's so easy to eat
it's very high in protein as well and
yeah I'd never get bored of this
sometimes I like to put this into my
soup as well and just make fish soup
so the sweet potato is done again scoop
it out let it cool down and this will be
our complex carbs everything is done so
now we have to allow all the food to
cool down to room temperature and then
Terrance is going to slice the chicken
breast
salmon as well as the beef and we're
good to store them into containers and
bring it out with us for lunch as well
as dinner
so now we're plating up for lunch and
also dinner his portion is almost three
times my portion so I always joke that
what he eats in a day I can eat in at
least two to three days so as you can
see everything was just pan pan fried
lightly pan fried a very little oil and
we used a lot of herbs and spices to
really bring out the flavor for each of
the meat
finally my mail purge all right so
usually I will eat about three filets
for each meal and that's about 100 to
120 grams of purge and the rest is for
him whatever I cannot finish or whatever
that's leftover it goes there yeah my
weight and sermon and again this is
about 100 220 grams of salmon so in
total I get about 250 grams of fish so
now I'm going to plate the vegetables
and as you can see we like to keep the
make sure the vegetables are really dry
so that it will last the whole day
EBIT de Leon can have one jinlun Canada
22 now I don't I do for you
and so this is for lunch and dinner
Terrence's portion is at least three
times more than mine in total if you
look at this
it's about 2300 calories and about 330
grams of protein you're after that's for
his body weight and that's for the kind
of training he does because he's a men's
physique bodybuilder so he needs to eat
a lot more for mine combined is almost
900 calories each meal I'm talking about
vegetables as well it's about 450
calories and in terms of protein is
about 90 grams of protein combined for
one whole day so guys if you enjoyed
this video if you have to watch more
videos of us together whether it's
cooking working out be sure to give this
video a thumbs up
show this emoji below yeah the muscle
emoji leave your comments let me know
what do you want to watch more off and
hopefully we'll film more videos and
don't forget okay to subscribe to my
channel and also his channel all the
best